i'm gonna be honest i love pizza even
more and we are down to the final four
in our eight news now pizza bracket yeah
that's right you voted you voted and now
we have the first of our four finalists
in the pizza bracket it's lucino's owner
joey scalaro joining us live this
morning to talk about your own shop joey
thanks for joining us this morning how
you doing today
thank you guys i'm doing great this
morning how are you guys oh well we're
excited to talk about pizza so you have
to tell us first i mean you must be
excited to be part of the final four
because you're relatively new to the
valley at least your shop is
yes um it's really exciting for me and
my family we're just a small little
pizza shop here in the valley and it's
really important to something like me
and my family where you know we just
opened up prior to the pandemic and you
know we were here today and especially
with all the other pizza shops that were
involved in this bracket too so
you know those pizza shops that are
involved they have been around for a
while so it means a lot to us just to be
so brand new to be this far into this
bracket all right so joey i see the the
little banner behind you there straight
out of philly so i assume when we're
talking it's going to be sort of like a
delco style pizza here what kind of
what's your what's the kind of pizza we
get you get at lucinos
so uh i like to just say you get when
you walk in here or east coast style
pizza you know um
new york style traditional thin crust
pizza that's that's what we were
thriving with back at home and
we brought it out here to the west coast
you know
oh look they're calling it now they want
deliveries right now yeah look they're
already they're already starting
they're excited uh what what is the
secret to your pizza is there a secret
ingredient or way you make it what what
makes it so special
um i would like to say that it has a lot
to do with uh the help of my father a
lot you know he came over from italy
came with that experience and
i i really gotta say he's he's a
blessing to me and that's really the
secret to everything my dad's
i love it you know that dad's touch and
pass it on to me and you know we just
put a lot of love into everything that
we put in
our making this pizzeria and you know we
don't stop doing that just at pizza we
do that with every single product that
we make in this
establishment we try to make sure that
everybody can feel that when they eat it
well joey real quick before we go tell
us where people can find you where are
you in town
so we are located in east las vegas off
of the tropicana and pecos right there
on the corner we sit right behind the
burger king next door to the 7-eleven
and uh you can't miss us we're one of
the busiest uh in east las vegas right
there on that on that highway right
there so one of them can't miss us
fans so yeah all right
better luck next week i think armando is
our photographer
and uh thank you guys for the trying to
slice when we get a chance appreciate it
thanks for getting it back no i can't
wait
i want to see the pizza where's his
pizza well he's making the dough right
now he's getting calls all around
a reminder you can vote for your
favorite pizza joint at 8newsnow.com
it's naked city versus lucinos and
giordano's is up against dom de marcos
you have until saturday at midnight to
cast your vote